how did idris elba fare as the voice of
knuckles which parts in a movie all
about speed meander at times keep
watching for how sonic the hedgehog 2
excelled and where it fell short warning
spoilers for sonic 2 are ahead
comedy icon jim carrey returns his
doctor robotnik in sonic the hedgehog 2
and naturally he steals every scene he's
in the only thing he's lacking is the
unique physique of the character from
the games but that has no ill effect on
his performance while the rest of the
cast is still on uneven ground acting
against their cgi co-stars carrie isn't
having any trouble keeping up with the
pixelated protagonists the funny secret
formula that has kept carrie running for
decades is still a joy to watch if this
is the last time we'll see carrie on the
big screen as he's recently suggested
there are worse ways to go out than
having another crack at dr robotnik
carrie recently broke the news that he
will be retiring from the big screen
after the second try to bring down a
fictitious fast hedgehog i have enough
i've done enough
i am enough
fans have to wonder then what that will
mean for the future of the franchise if
it won't have its original villain given
the closing scenes of sonic the hedgehog
2 it's clear that a shadow will no doubt
be cast over the next film perhaps
filling the spot of carries robotnik as
the film's big bad could shadow be the
same kind of draw as carrie with a
shaved head and wide reaching facial
hair only time will tell
plenty of anthropomorphic animal icons
have been brought to life by well-known
voice actors but casting a big name to
portray an animated creature isn't
always a short bet remember bill murray
as garfield or could you name any of the
voice actors behind the 2014 teenage
mutant ninja turtles movie thankfully
ben schwartz nailed his performance as
sega's mascot straight out the gate in
sonic the hedgehog 2 he continues to
impress the former parks and recreation
star's vibrancy and charm continue to
flow effortlessly into what could easily
have been another throwaway kids movie
sure there might be some iffy one-liners
but schwartz breathes life into a
character that rarely seems to stop for
air he gives sonic heart and humor in
equal balance and whenever a cheesy
moment does slip through the cracks it's
permissible simply because of short's
performance
while sonic's sequel does have plenty of
highs the lows sure do stand out for
example sonic the hedgehog 2 includes
something that feels like a staple of
family-friendly films centered around
kooky cgi characters but just because
it's a staple doesn't mean that it's a
good idea sonic heads off to siberia and
gets into a tense encounter with the
locals to help alleviate the tension
tails does some searching to find a
local custom that could help sonic
relate to these folks and determines
that a dance-off just might work what
follows is not only a paint by number
sequence that brings the film to a
screeching halt but it highlights some
of the film's worst cgi as sonic and
tails go from looking reasonably
realistic to having all the on-screen
presence of stuffed animals
idris elba famously promised that his
portrayal of knuckles and sonic 2 would
not be sexy you're no match for me
we'll let the fans decide if the
smoldering star was right about that but
what we can say for sure is that his
performance as the fist throwing frenemy
surpasses expectations much like
schwartz and carrie as their respective
characters elba manages to slowly make
this legendary bruiser his own mainly by
following in the footsteps of some
beloved characters from another
franchise the character of knuckles made
his debut in sega genesis game sonic the
hedgehog 3 in 1994 and this crimson
colored echidna has always felt like the
group's rogue he's the raphael or red
hood of the team who isn't afraid to get
his mitts dirty and can crack wise as
much as the heroic hedgehog here though
knuckles is more like our favorite
cinematic god of thunder thor he's a
rough and tumble fish out of water who
is all about honor he wants to fight
first and ask questions later seeing his
character develop is easily one of the
film's biggest highlights
every bad guy needs some backup but
robotnik's lackey agent stone
unfortunately doesn't cut it this time
around sonic's sworn enemy is too busy
making a shady alliance with knuckles
for the former partner in crime to make
an impact stone's fleeting appearances
quickly feel redundant lee majoob who
plays stone was a welcome addition in
the last film but here he's not given
enough to do audiences paid to see jim
carrey yelling at iconic video game
characters not stone overstaying his
welcome in scenes that lack the comedic
spark of the rest of the film feeling
like they're just there to move the film
along stone's presence stops them from
serving even that purpose efficiently
movies based on beloved franchises from
other media like comics and video games
don't always fit in references to the
lore of the source material particularly
well sometimes it feels shoehorned in
like the filmmakers were just checking
off items in a checklist which is why
it's a relief that the nods to sega's
prickly poster boy don't feel contrived
at all in sonic the hedgehog 2. they're
deployed judiciously and effectively and
that makes all the difference it's clear
that jeff fowler who joins the crew
again after handling directing duties
for the first film in 2020 still has a
love for sonic and his video game
history from tom's hilarious ringtone
the green hill level music in case you
missed it to sonic later dodging an
array of death traps in what looks to be
a level straight out of the games it
should all satisfy longtime fans
it can be risky for a movie named after
shiny cgi characters to focus on its
flesh and blood supporting actors for
too long the scenes with sam witwicky's
parents in the transformers franchise
are some of the most memorable offenders
in the case of sonic the hedgehog 2 it's
a wedding we weren't invited to that
delivers the same unwanted effect while
they weren't unwelcome additions in the
original film here tom wikowski his wife
maddie and sister-in-law rachel are part
of a b-plot that's not remotely as
compelling as seeing sonic's epic scrap
with knuckles hedgehog hating rachel is
going full bridezilla leading up to her
wedding in hawaii to a guy named randall
there is an alarming amount of time
spent on this breakup then makeup
journey without a hedgehog or echidna
hair in sight until the very end it is
unfortunately incredibly dull the film
could have easily given that time over
to sonic and his new pals and eliminated
this subplot altogether
heroes squaring off against each other
before learning that they're all on the
same side and should team up to take on
the real bad guy is a tradition as old
as time remember when tony stark asked
thor does mother no you wear as her
drapes
while it might not bring as much heat as
seeing marvel's finest go toe to toe
there's an undeniably epic feel to sonic
trying to outmaneuver his new foe
knuckles only to get the rings knocked
out of them in the first encounter the
eventual final round when they decide to
squash their digital beef might just be
the highlight of the entire film
starting with a wide shot that feels
like it's been ripped right out of a
classic sonic boss level what follows is
a gorgeous display of cgi as sonic and
knuckles apply their respective power
sets it feels like there's not a single
area of their battleground that isn't
used to great effect it should only get
more fans excited for the future foe
that makes an appearance after the
credits roll
sometimes sonic looks great you can
really suspend your disbelief at times
and believe that a blue hedgehog can
blast his way down the highway while
cracking wise occasionally his
supercharged quills gets splashed with
water or doused in sand and it's clear
that lots of effort has been put into
making it all work in a way that feels
like it could really exist on some
occasions though there are times when
none of it comes together besides that
diabolical dance-off there are moments
when an interaction with a real actor
falls apart and the human cast member's
eyeline is way off the mark in others
the size of the video game trio is
totally out of proportion between shots
these inconsistencies sometimes bring
the film down but mercifully they are
few and far between
thanks to marvel studios the
post-credits scene has become a required
element for any entry in a massive media
franchise thankfully the teaser at the
end of sonic the hedgehog 2 is one fans
should be excited about without a shadow
of a doubt with the supposed demise of
dr robotnik after our hero goes
supersonic the shifty organization gun
searches among the ruins for signs of
life what it finds is something far more
lethal enter dr robotnik's top secret
project shadow in the final shot we see
an iconic anti-hero from the sonic
universe wake up with eyes aflame and no
doubt ready to cause some damage to the
blue blur shadow the hedgehog sonic's
tough gun-toting occasional ally has
just entered the fray he could
potentially fill carry spot as top
antagonist if the actor's recent
retirement sticks
pg-rated movies have to strike a careful
balance of being able to entertain kids
and grown-ups in equal measure while
staying family friendly casting jim
carrey is definitely a good start toward
achieving that goal but sonic 2 has
among its many many gags some that just
don't land oh great the winter soldier
the worst offenders feel dated and
borderline offensive to put it simply
the film script makes a few questionable
zigs when it should have zagged while
quick enough to fly by there's no doubt
that these lame lines might not sit
right with some members of the audience
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie franchises are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]